So we know that grant started off with a
certain amount of money from the venture
capital funders. But then he doesn't just
keep it, he starts to spend it. This means
that the right choice must take both of
these into account, the money that he was
given initially and the money that he
spent so far. The second and last choices
only have one of these two things each, so
that means that neither of them can be
right. So I'm going to cross them both
out. So that just leaves us with these
two. Money from funders plus money spent,
or money from funders minus money spent.
Spending money, actually takes away from
the amount of money that we have. It
doesn't add to it. So that means that the
third choice, right here, money from
funders minus money spent must be the
right answer. Now without even trying
we've actually just done some math. I know
that there aren't any numbers here, but
what we've created is called an equation.
It's called that because of this equal
sign right here in the middle. Over doing
with this equation is showing that these
two quantities, the one on the left side
of the equal sign and the one on the right
side. Are equal to each other, or have the
same numerical value. This is the first of
many, many equations that we're going to
look at throughout this course. And over
time you'll learn to do a ton of different
things with them.